hey youtubers it's Charlie so yesterday
in my purple wedding video I asked you
to submit all your questions about the
episode as well as season 4 so I picked
10 of them to answer in this video with
one bonus question we also have one new
king to crown in the giveaway
congratulations to list Nagas high fives
you win a $20 Amazon gift card I'll be
reaching out to you on your channel for
contact details you can either use it to
buy something cool or help the crown
repay its debt to the iron bank I think
it still owes them about 3 million gold
coins so that might put a dent in it the
next round of the giveaway will start
next week whenever I post my episode 3
review on Sunday all you have to do to
participate is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on those videos so let's
speechify some purple wedding and answer
some questions careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen the episode yet but
here we go question number one comes
from Santa Claus who was the voice brand
heard in his head so he was actually
hearing the voice of the three-eyed
Raven also known as the green seer you
can think of green seers as like extra
powerful wargs with power over all of
nature it works a little differently
from worgen but what's bran finds him I
think the show will explain that in
greater detail we actually do know quite
a bit about the green seer himself he
used to be called the Bloodraven and
when he was alive his real name was
Brynden rivers he was the son of Aegon
Targaryen the fourth in a black wood the
black woods are from the river lands so
that's why his bastard name is rivers
and not black fire I'll actually be
dedicating one of my Sunday bonus videos
to the Bloodraven
I know a lot of you guys have been
asking for that video so since we're PI
not gonna see bran again for two more
episodes I'll probably wait till before
episode 4 to post that question number 2
salade asks will we see your on Greyjoy
this season so the strange thing about
the Ironborn this season are is is that
we might only see Theon sister because
she's headed to moat Cailin and that's
also where Ramsay snow is headed with
Theon your on doesn't really appear
until book 4 and right now we're still
in book 3 where the show is right now
even Daenerys stuff is still in book 3
right now I'm actually really hoping the
show doesn't totally cut him out of the
story because he's one of the more
interesting book characters that we get
to meet eventually the interesting thing
though is is that his brother Victarion
is a POV character but you're on is not
even though you're on is kinda the more
interesting one question number three
Blake Targaryen asks
do you think that Daenerys dragons will
ever reproduce so I actually talked a
little bit about this during my dragon
history bonus video but dragons can
actually switch genders that means that
drogon could become a male and this
Aryan and ragel could become female
george RR martin hasn't officially
revealed anything about the dragons
laying new eggs and the books but I
definitely think it's gonna happen
eventually I'll be sure to post a link
to that dragon bonus video in the
description below question number four
Geoffrey Bayne Aki asks what did Joffrey
do that makes everyone hate him so much
so I know you're just trying to play
devil's advocate but I'm just gonna list
off of some of his more notable crimes
against humanity
he had Sansa's dire wolf lady killed
beheaded Ned Stark after he promised not
to force Sansa to look at his head on a
pike ordered Sansa to be stripped and
beaten in the throne room killed Ross
with a crossbow turned sword on toast
into his court jester and ordered dwarfs
to reenact the war of the five kings
that sir Dontos think kind of seems to
be coming back around on him just a
little bit and in real life sophie
turner ended up adopting the lady the
wolf that played the dire wolf so there
is a bit of a happy ending number five
dark architect asks i think penny may
have been the one under the wolf's head
during the dwarf jousting
so after re-watching the episode i
actually saw a picture here I'll
actually put it up right now
I think this person's costume looks like
penny like they made this prop to look
like her during the scene in the books
she actually wrote a pig if you want to
reread that part in the books is
actually in book 3 chapter 60 question
number 6 Jack O'Connor asks do you think
we'll see any White Walkers in the next
two episodes so there are scenes with
the wildlings and the Nights Watch in
the next episode but if we're just
talking about the next two episodes then
I think we'll see that white Walker from
the trailer just because most of the
trailer footage includes stuff from the
first couple of episodes I actually saw
that a lot of you guys thought that that
white Walker and the trailer could have
been cold hands the footage isn't great
and it's not a super close-up so it's
hard to tell
cold hands actually resembles more of a
white than he does a white Walker so
they could just be making him look
different that could be him in the
trailer question number 7 Lisbeth says
what about when the red Viper kindly
reminds Cersei that Marcela is still
living in Dorne
so I didn't have a lot of room in my
review video so I kind of had to leave
it out but yes that was actually a
really important and really interesting
scene
it sounded like Oberon was just
suggesting that Marcella was safe from
all the awfulness by being in Dorne but
at the same time it could have also been
a threat as in Marcella was in Dorne and
was at their mercy and could be
potentially subjected to all those
things if the Martel's wanted Prince
Doran is actually one of the more
level-headed Martell so I don't think
they'd ever officially hurt Marcella
whenever they sent her down there she
actually became betrothed to one of the
other young Martell princes like one of
the really young ones the look on
Tywin's face is pretty priceless though
it's like he's envisioning all the
trouble that Oberon is gonna cost him
while he searches for more information
about his sister question number 8 David
McDowell blue asks what did you think
Cersei is going to be like now so you're
talking about after Joffrey's death but
before that she was on a tear way before
Joffrey ever started choking one of my
favorite moments is when that servant
girl came up and muttered under her
breath to maester pycelle and Cersei
just interrupts her and says go seek why
burn if he didn't catch it she's just
talking about getting an abortion Susi
had also been talking about quite burnt
in episode one as if she'd been using
him to get like special drugs to help
her sleep like he's the shady doctor you
would go to to get free drugs after this
though she's just gonna be in mourning
for a few episodes and generally
horrible to everyone around her you know
way more than usual in general though I
think things are just gonna continue to
get shittier and shittier for her though
things just continue to get worse
question number nine ladies Elda asks is
Jack Gleeson going off to complete his
education now so he did talk about
wanting to quit acting and pursue higher
education he and his friends actually do
a puppet show on the side whenever Game
of Thrones is it filming so I don't
think he'll ever completely leave the
performing arts you know he'll still do
creative things but he probably won't
try to star in another big television
series David Benioff and DB Weiss
actually said that they wouldn't be
surprised if he ended up becoming a
professor so it sounds like he might
just eventually enroll in a ph.d program
and try to become a professor so he
might actually be able to take a class
from Professor Joffrey in the future
question number 10 nicholas Peloso asks
will we see more Littlefinger he hasn't
been around recently so at the end of
last season Littlefinger went to the
Eyrie to woo Catelyn sister so that he
could marry her and
their title in all our lands in the Vale
we will probably see him in Episode
three or four depending on how many
king's landing scenes there are and one
last bonus question
Shelly asks what will happen to Marjorie
now that she's the queen but Joffrey is
dead
so Tywin in the small Council will
basically just kind of wash their hands
of the marriage because it was never
consummated that just means there's
grounds for an annulment side note you
probably could not divorce a corpse but
either way she won't get to be queen
she'll just go back and live with her
family that's what that preview scene
with her and Olenna was from the episode
3 clip she was just talking about almost
becoming Queen and Elena is telling her
that things are gonna be better with
Joffrey dead so thank you so much guys
for submitting all these questions it's
always a lot of fun to do these kind of
videos my next bonus video will probably
be something about the conflict between
the wildlings and the Nights Watch just
because that's gonna be a big deal in
the next episode right now click here to
watch my review the episode and click
here to get my bonus purple wedding
video where I just go a little bit more
to tell about the wedding itself so
thank you so much for watching this is a
lot of fun see you guys tomorrow high
fives
you